every time we have a conversation about
how much artists producers songwriters
are paid it is so confusing there there
are just so many different scenarios
whether you're listening on Spotify for
free whether you're paying premium just
how exactly should we think about how
artists producers and songwriters are
paid by these streaming services well
the interesting thing is what we have
now are technology companies using music
to generate revenue through IPOs through
selling hardware software gaining market
share for example Spotify is worth over
8 billion dollars but loses money on
music every single day and the challenge
that they have is they must get licenses
to the recording of a song and to the
lyric and melody of the song to complete
separate distinct copyrights find out
who they are get a license and make
those payments now in a per use rate
versus the old model where people would
buy pre-recorded music so there's this
major transition occurring and Apple
could conceivably change the entire
market overnight with over 800 million
credit cards on file the infrastructure
to deliver the music the world's music
library at the click of a button it
literally could shift consumer behavior
so if the model isn't properly set now
it could strip mine and decimate an
entire culture a music industry and not
give us a viable future for the
musicians artists and labels there seems
to be something fundamentally wrong
though with the culture if Apple thought
to begin with that it wouldn't have to
pay anything to artists and producers
and songwriters for three full months I
mean Jeff I don't get this well it
unfortunately is a precedent that's been
set by the major record labels and dates
back over ten years what we had was an
inside baseball terminology free trial
subscriptions and what was wonderful
about Taylor Swift is she brought this
behind-the-scenes thing out into the
foray into the public so we're now
actually talking about it and you're
absolutely right what was being asked is
for artists labels songwriters music
publishers to absorb the cost of
customer acquisition on behalf of a
technology company because that's the
way it's always been and Taylor Swift
this isn't about Taylor Swift versus
Apple this is about the entire music
industry fighting to be to be monetized
why why are we only hearing from Taylor
Swift Keith why why aren't we hearing
from other artists why isn't everybody
complaining well I first of all that's
who pays you so you want to be careful
about who you complain about I think
Taylor Swift is in a position and she's
powerful enough to make a great
statement here but the point that Jeff
made is a real
good one this was set not just 10 years
ago this was said many years ago before
the internet before Napster before all
these things came along the music
industry as we know it is based on two
revenue streams it's based on physical
goods selling and now it added the
digital streams now the physical goods
are really going away it is the digital
music business that is the business so
it is important to keep in mind that the
they are running on roads that are
really not made for the new technologies
I think what Apple has done especially
what Eddy Cue is done in responding to
Taylor Taylor expressed that Apple's a
partner expressed that Apple's a partner
and now that is an opportunity for them
to build a bridge and work not just with
Apple but with Spotify and with all the
other streaming services as well you
know what does this mean for Spotify
should Spotify be terrified that you
know Apple has deep pockets and can sort
of do whatever artists want
whereas Spotify is a start-up and can't
necessarily just pay artists when they
complain no not at all it's a time where
the model has to be addressed what I
think what the great thing about what
Taylor Swift has done along with guys
that people like IO Siri and other
people who are managing a lot of these
different types of artists they are
making us take a look right now why the
cement is still wet to go ahead and
let's look at this business model let's
take a good hard look at how this
business model is being cut up because
that is important and let's not forget
yes it's the music business but music is
a arts and it takes artists to make them
it takes artists to sit in studios it
takes artists to make this whole thing
work and you have to show respect to
that so just obviously pre-recorded
music sales are declining and Taylor
said herself she's making her music from
live tours from performing what does the
streaming music industry look like in
five years well that's exactly the
question that needs to get answered it
needs to get answered now you see
Spotify isn't about generating revenue
Spotify is about getting an exit kleiner
perkins invested money and they want
their 10x returned and there's nothing
wrong with that
the problem is along the way is the
business model the right model or are we
going to have an exit for a technology
company reaping billions for the
original investors while decimating the
industry by setting the bar too low and
what's wonderful what Apple just did
today is it raises the bar
did inadvertently was create a way to
get a second wave of publicity right by
saying we're gonna pay for these free
trial subscriptions while looking like a
company with a soul on a good guy and I
can see apples perspective by the way
what they have is this great new product
with 800 million potential users for it
and they want to get everyone in to try
it everyone on the planet can now try
this new product for 90 days and if they
like it it will just continue and all of
a sudden the amount of potential revenue
for music copyright holders will
skyrocket and if the model works
correctly there will be more money now
through recorded and streamed music than
ever before so you asked the right
question what will it look like in 3
years because right now as the top line
revenue is going up for entities like
Spotify the amount of money that we're
making it the per stream rate is going
down people are making less money as
Spotify grows its top-line revenue and
that scares me a lot